today we're at Coelho ranch and this is
one of my favorite places in Hawaii it
was so beautiful it's 4,000 acres
they've shot so many amazing movies here
if you've seen a movie where it looks
like the Hawaii setting there's a really
good chance they shot it here at the
ranch you're about to do in the bike
tour and when we booked this tour we
thought that it was gonna be like a
fully electric bike tour but it's pedal
assist and this place is over 4,000
acres we're about to hop on and this is
gonna be an iPhone 10 our vlog so most
of the clips will be iPhone hen art but
I'm kind of afraid to melt this so I'm
gonna mount one of my 360 cameras
footage
oh do you remember what this place was
you scared me so bad this is where Jenna
and that scared the crap out of me I was
in here just like video I like talking
about some stuff and then you guys
scared that's our new friend
Dalton grab his name do you remember I
do I remember but he said we can call
him up Newport Beach this bunker was
completed two years after the war so
that means that's not efficient I just
wanna show you what I got here
GoPro foam water 360 camera this is what
we call tech fashion I breathe
[Music]
so tell me a better show tell me about
it
tell me a better show
[Music]
[Applause]
there's a nice or drones one of the
other times that we were here and oh my
gosh don't worry yet and I am very
nervous
Bri what did you do
Brie's bike is broken and we're out of
radio cell service the breeze changes
broke and like it actually broke like it
didn't just like pop off like it's lit
Jenna it's really great idea
I did let's test it out the iPhone 10 R
detects people when you're taking a
courser mode so she said we'll take this
person you do a job
I don't think it's a it's it's not a
person I just think was just a thought
[Music]
this is a branch hero right here in case
you didn't like to vlog on here looks
like did you guys order an iPhone 10 our
if you did let me know in the comments
below what told you about it if you did
it what color would you get
[Music]
aha I just finished editing this video
and I thought that you guys are probably
gonna have some questions about how I
did the fisheye effects and a bunch of
those are the sort of like I four last
things I did use that 360 camera that I
mentioned before it's to 361 X and I did
use my iPhone 10s to edit those and then
I imported those into Final Cut to
finish editing this whole vlog so
technically this vlog was pretty much
all done on an iPhone I'm pretty
impressed again thanks for watching and
look for my unboxing of all of the ten
hour colors coming very very shortly as
soon as ups drops them off and I film
the video and edit it it'll be up here
for you guys to enjoy until then I'll
see you later and that's it
I think that's all I wanted to tell you
[Music]